this program is brought to you by Emory
University
I had a love or respect four equations
and number
I realize medicine was there was a lot
of art in it and I try to somehow use
computers as a tool to help objectify
the process of extracting quantitative
parameters and using those to come up
with objective decision making the the
feel of nuclear medicine nuclear
cardiology was really one of the first
fuels in medicine to quantify parameters
from images and so putting together by
scientific background and my computer
background started developing techniques
to diagnose heart disease and more
specifically through all these years the
technique that has been used quite a bit
that we helped pioneer is myocardial
perfusion imaging specifically the
aspects of quantifying myocardial
perfusion really means blood flow to the
muscle of the heart and so we have
techniques they have been developed at
one injects radioactive tracers that go
to the muscle the heart what our team
has done for many years is use those
images to look at blood flow to look at
the efficiency of the heart beating and
it keeps growing from there in many
different tools the these tools are
being developed and have been in fact
commercialized and iterative worldwide
over 30,000 licenses for the the tool
that we call the American toolbox and so
basically helps physicians from
everywhere to come up with better
diagnosis of whether the patient has
coronary disease or not the United
States in 2005 10 million patients were
image with this technique they were two
or three significant barriers at the
beginning the first one had to do with
issues like should we even use computers
in medicine being part of a whole
movement of trying to
make physicians understand that we need
to objectify the diagnostic process
software was giving away for free at the
time and so they had to be an
understanding that for for these tools
to move forward the people would have to
pay for them and which then took quite a
bit to convince companies to
commercialize it in to charge for it so
that's not the commercial aspect but
really we thought the commercial aspect
it's just like a drug it would not exist
and and so what promoted me to innovate
is basically the fact that realizing
that this could help and it does help
the diagnostic process that why not that
can the beautiful computers is that once
you have the software it can be run
anywhere and it could help people in
other places and not only for example at
Emory we have great physicians and still
the computer helps them with the
objective fala diagnostic process but in
other places where they have less
training on the specific techniques the
computer is even more helpful the most
important one is the one that quantifies
myocardial perfusion and what this does
is it looks at a large database of
patients both patients that were found
to be normal and patients to be found to
be abnormal and statistically looks at
the images and compares them to this
files to add to to flag whether this
particular patient or this particular
heart in a particular region is it's
lacking blood flow either doing exercise
or doing rest and then comparing one to
the other the other tools are related to
measuring the function of the left
ventricle so the left ventricle is the
main part of the heart that pumps blood
to the rest of the body so how well it
works as a pump I think really
incredibly important as to the status of
the disease and
and so again it's an objective number
and this is also measure from the same
study so from the same study we we were
able to measure many different things
from the beginning I realized that I
wanted to develop something that it
would be used in patients in other words
that it would be really frustrating to
come up with good tools that would only
use locally the preceding program is
copyrighted by emory university